بريطانيا تقلب الموازين التقليديه وتدخل
اوسع ابواب الطب
باختبار دم ثوري يكشف اكثر من 50 سرطانا
كشف تحليل الدم الذي سمي جاليري نتيجه
فوريه دقيقه وصحيحه بواقع ثلاثه وتسعين
بالمئه نوعين من كل ثلاثه انواع من
السرطان لدى خمسه الاف شخص في 85% من تلك
الحالات الايجابيه تم تحديد الموقع الاصلي
للسرطان عن طريق فحص عينه الدم فقط بينما
تم اثبات اصابه قرابه 75% من المرضى
بالسرطان باختبار الدم ليس ذلك فحسب بل
وصحح نتائج ظهرت قبل التحليل السلبيه
بواقع 2.5
تحليل جاليري بانه مغير لقواعد اللعبه
فوفقا للباحثين من جامعه اوكسفورد يستطيع
هذا التحليل التعرف على انواع السرطانيه
صعبه والتشخيص في المراحل المبكره مثل
سرطانات الراس والعنق المبيض والبنكرياس
والمريء تعتمد اليه عمل الاختبار على بحث
التغييرات مميزه في اجزاء من الشفره
الوراثيه التي تتسرب من انواع السرطان
المختلفه والخفيه تستخدم هيئه الخدمات
الصحيه الوطنيه البريطانيه اختبارا جاليري
على الاف الاشخاص حول البلاد لمساعده
الاطباء على اكتشاف حاله السرطان بصوره
مبكره ثم التدخل السريعا لانقاذ حياه
المريض وفي حال اثبتت نتائج العام الحالي
الاوليه نجاحها تخطط وهيئه الصحه
ببريطانيا توسع النطاق ليشمل مليون شخص
اضافي خلال العامين القادمين
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات